so let's forget the best piece of advice
you've ever received let's talk about
the worst piece of advice let's work
backwards the worst piece of advice you
ever received regarding acting or
filmmaking without naming any names of
course or any identifying you know
things and why why was it faulty there's
so much bad advice out there but hmm
yeah I'm trying to sort through you can
do a jump cut to when we find anything
or areas what's the worst advice I've
ever gotten but someone suggested that
you start speaking in a british accent
we were talking to a manager and if you
pretend it out more Australian because
the people is that actually bad advice
though I might because I back it was
immoral advice right and but yeah I was
talking about Lady Gaga as an example of
someone who wasn't doing well and then
created this persona so that was weird
advice because they're impressed when
you walk in as a brita Australian and
then you do a great American accent the
actual audition they're like oh she can
really do something so maybe you should
do that is a really great advice all
right nope none do your dick van dyke
yes okay so no one's ever given advice
on stage names or coming up with sort of
a gimmick other than that well her name
is anna devine which no one believes is
a real and real name in the first place
all I know maybe you should change maybe
I should be changed my name to divide
yeah yeah Gabriel divine I'll take your
name
you